faites des affaires au portugal voici
comment on pourrait résumer cette
matinée des changes à versailles
co-organisée par deux sociétés franco
portugaise de conseil en entreprise une
vingtaine d'entrepreneurs avaient
répondu présent il ya plus qu'un million
et sans que 5000 portugais qui sont qui
sont en france donc la rédaction c'est
une réaction très bonne d'affirmation de
la communauté et notre économie elle se
développe en tout cas avec cette cette
relation de confiance
depuis ces dernières années le portugal
bénéficie d'une des meilleures
croissances économiques de la zone euro
tourisme métallurgie ou encore commerce
extérieur les opportunités d'un ferry
sont nombreuses aussi bien pour les
entreprises versaillaise que portugaise
on a connu des gens très intéressants
des entrepreneurs qui veut travailler
avec nous qu'ils sont curieux qui vont
voir ce qu'on fait et ça porte ses
qualités de qualité européenne qu toutes
les certifications dans notre métier et
un prix très compétitif
il y un chiffre qui m'a beaucoup
interpellé dans la présentation c'est
tout bêtement le chiffre du pib par tête
par habitant on ya 15000 euros portugal
j'ai regardé combien on était en france
on à 35000 vous fait le ratio des deux
vous avez compris et que le coût du
travail au portugal laurent le pays
extrêmement attractif notamment pour les
activités de services après cette
première édition positive pour les
organisateurs d'autres rencontre devrait
avoir lieu au cours de l'année